>> TALK ABOUT "THE BIG SATURDAY
SHOW".
TAKING HEAT FROM THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY THOSE ATTACKS ARE NOTHING
NEW.
REMEMBER WHEN ACTIVISTS FOLLOWED
HER INTO THE BATHROOM TO YELL AT
HER?
>> WE NEED SOLUTIONS TO BUILD
BACK A BETTER PLAN.
>> WE KNOCKED ON DOORS FOR YOU
TO GET YOU ELECTED JUST HOW WE
GOT ELECTED WE CANNOT WE CAN GET
YOU OUT OF OFFICE IF YOU DO NOT
SUPPORT WHAT YOU PROMISED US.
>> HUMAN TRAFFICKING.
[INAUDIBLE]
>> LIBERALS WENT OFF WHEN THEY
HEARD SINEMA DITCH THE DEMOCRATS
AND AOC SAME PEOPLE DESERVE
MORE.
SHE'D BE SO MUCH HAPPIER RUNNING
A BURLESQUE THEMED KNITTING
STORE FORMER MSNBC HOST KEITH
OLBERMANN WRITING YOU ARE
ETHICALLY UNFIT TO CONTINUE
SERVING AS A UNITED STATES
SENATOR.
I ALWAYS LOVE THE WOMEN
SUPPORTING WOMEN.
IT'S DETESTED IN MY BOOK.
I WANT TO GO TO YOU ON THE
SWING, JASON.
YOU KNOW KRYSTEN SINEMA.
YOU SERVED WITH HER.
THIS IS INTERESTING ME SHE CHOSE
TO CHANGE TO AN INDEPENDENT
PAIRED LOT OF FOLKS ON BOTH
SIDES OF THE AISLE SAID SHE DID
THIS TO ESCAPE WHAT WOULD BE A
DIFFICULT DEMOCRAT PRIMARY
CHALLENGER.
SHE KIND OF DID THIS AS A COP
OUT.
DO YOU THINK THIS WAS A
POLITICALLY SOUND STRATEGY FOR
SENATOR COMING FROM PURPLE STATE
LIKE ARIZONA?
IS THIS GOING TO WORK OUT FOR
HER?
>> I DID SERVED IN THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES FOR THE PERSON
GOING THROUGH WONDERFULLY.
I TRULY THINK SHE IS
INDEPENDENT-MINDED AND THAT
PLAYS WELLIN ARIZONA.
BUT I THINK MORE THAN EVER THIS
SEAT WILL NOW GO TO REPUBLICANS.
DEMOCRATS CANNOT RESIST IT.
THEY ARE SO FAR TO THE LEFT
THERE ALMOST RECOGNIZABLE TO THE
GENERAL PUBLIC.
THEY FEEL THE CANDIDATE IS A
DEMOCRAT.
SHE RUNS AS AN INDEPENDENT.
THAT SPLITS THE VOTE REPUBLICAN
CAN THEN GO IN AND WHEN THE
MAJORITY.
I DON'T THINK SHE CAN BE
REELECTED AS A DEMOCRAT ON THE
BOUT IN ARIZONA I DON'T THINK
THAT WOULD HAPPEN BUT.
>> HARRIS YOU SPENT SOME TIME
WITH HER AS WELLIN A MUCH
DIFFERENT POLITICAL TIME IN
2016.
SPEAKING TO HER AND TALKING TO
HER ABOUT WHAT SHE PLANS TO DO.
DID YOU GET THE SENSE FROM HER
SHE WAS A SOLID DEMOCRAT OR WAS
SHE MORE INDEPENDENT, LIBERALS
RIGHT NOW SHE ACTS LIKE A
REPUBLICAN WITH COMPLETE WRITTEN
OR OFFERED.
>> A DO NOT LIKE HER BECAUSE
THEY COULD NOT CONTROL HER.
THEY DO NOT HAVE A LOT OF LOVE
FOR MANCHIN IN WEST VIRGINIA WHO
IS ALSO INDEPENDENT-MINDED AT
TIMES.
HE DID NOT GET WHAT HE WENT FROM
THE INFLATION REDUCTION ACT WAS
GETTING UGLY.
I DON'T THINK YOU'RE GOING TO
SIMPLE THIS DANCE MOVE THIS IS
SPECIFIC TO HER.
YES BACK IN LATE 2,152,016 THE
GROUP LOOKED AT HER AND SAID SHE
VOTED IN LINE WITH THE TRUNK
POLICIES NORTH TO 50% CLOSE TO
50% OF THE TIME.
THIS IS SOMETHING SHE'S BEEN
DOING ALL ALONG BEING
INDEPENDENT ON CERTAIN ISSUES
BUT IT WORKS IN ARIZONA FOR THIS
REASON.
THEY HAVE A LOT OF CALIFORNIANS
MOVED IN NOW PART OF THE U-HAUL
TRUCKS IN CALIFORNIA CANNOT GET
BACK.
AND BECAUSE OF THAT SHE IS GOING
TO HAVE TO BE DIFFERENT.
SHE DID NOT DO ENOUGH AT THE
BORDER, SHE DID SOME.
BUT SHE DID MORE THAN MARK KELLY
THE DEMOCRAT HAD TO BE DRAGGED
OUT OF THERE.
THE POLES HAD TO SHOW HIS TIME.
SO SHE DOES HAVE THE ABILITY TO
RUN THAT WAY I AGREE WITH JASON
I THINK THIS SEAT GOES UP TO THE
REPUBLICAN AGAINST I DON'T AND
THE DEMOCRATS ARE GOING TO POUR
MONEY BEHIND HER BECAUSE I DO
NOT THINK SO EITHER.
I THINK THIS IS A STRONG MOVE I
NOTE YOU WATCH HER COME I KNOW
YOU WATCH EVERY DAY YOU ARE
FAMILIAR WITH THIS CLIP.
JUST IN CASE THOSE OF YOU OUT
THERE DO NOT WATCH OF YOU LET'S
TAKE A LISTEN I WANT YOU TO
WATCH FOR JIM'S STEAK ON THE
OTHER SIDE.
>> 'S PARTY IS NOTHING FOR THEY
HAVE NOTHING THEY HAVE NO
PLATFORM THEY HAVE NOTHING FOR
IT THEY DO IS HANG OUT WITH
NAZIS WENT WHITE SUPREMACIST.
THERE THE PARTIES ACTUALLY DOING
SOMETHING FOR PEOPLE LIKE US BUT
THEY ARE WORKING FAMILIES, THE
GAY PEOPLE FOR VOTING RIGHTS.
AND SHE'S LIKE WHAT SHOULD I DO?
WHAT'S BIZARRE DEMOCRATS VOTED
FOR A DEMOCRAT.
THEY DIDN'T VOTE FOR AN
INDEPENDENT.
FOR HER TO SAY THIS IS ALWAYS
WHO I'VE BEEN THIS SHOULD HAVE
BEEN HEARD FROM THE BEGINNING.
CHRISTIE DON'T THINK CHANGE YOUR
TITLE IS GOING TO MAKE IN YOUR
NOW ONE OF US.
>> ON THE VIEW I'M NOT A WATCHER
BUT I DO SEE CLIPS HERE AND
THERE.
I HAVE BEEN ON THE VIEW I LOVE
THE LADIES.
JOIN OUR BEST SEASON SEEING HER
LADY, JUST KIDDING.
LAP AT.
[LAUGHTER]
WOMEN SUPPORTING WOMEN.
NOW THEY ARE SAYING KRYSTEN
SINEMA IT'S OKAY IF HE FELL YOU
INTO THE BATHROOM.
IT'S OKAY IF WE INTIMIDATE YOU.
KEEP SAYING YOU'RE POLITICALLY
UNFIT MORALLY UNFIT.
THEY TURNED ON HER ON A DIME.
IS THIS ENDEMIC CRAB PARTY THAT
RISER DIES WITH EACH OTHER?
>> IS A PROGRESSIVE ACTIVIST RED
HATS OFF TO THEM THEY RUN OFF AN
ELECTED OFFICIAL THEY ACTUALLY
NEED IN THEIR PARTY THEY RUN OFF
DEMOCRATIC VOTERS WOULD
REPUBLICANS WERE SERIOUS ABOUT
WINNING THEY SHOULD HIRE
PROGRESSIVE ACTIVISTS ARE GOING
TO HARASS DEMOCRATS BECAUSE
THEY'RE NOT WOKE ENOUGH.
THIS IS WHAT WE HAVE COME TO IN
AMERICA.
SUCH A SHAME FOLKS CANNOT GIVE
THEIR VIEWPOINT HAVE
INDEPENDENCE FROM THEIR PARTY
BUT I AM A CONSERVATIVE IF
CONSERVATIVES DO SOMETHING I
DON'T LIKE OR LOSE AWAY FROM THE
IDEOLOGY AND MAY NOT SUPPORT
THEM OR CALL THEM OUT.
THAT IS WHERE WE SHOULD BE AS A
COUNTRY.
THEY WANT TO MISS A BEAT MARRIED
TO THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY AND DO
WHATEVER JOE BIDEN SAYS THAT'S
THE WRONG MOVE.
I APPRECIATE HER LEAVING I THINK
JOE MANCHIN SHOULD LEAVE AS WELL
BECAUSE SHE ALSO SAYS SHE'S